il est
le clone d' emmanuel macron du moins le
clown politique il a été son serviteur
politique donc je vois pas pourquoi les
français ne voulant plus des manuels
macro on voudrait d'une pâle copie
parfaite vous dire qui a été son
collaborateur il est ce que nous voulons
vraiment aller vers le nucléaire
continuer à soutenir une industrie qui
est un florent pour notre pays moi je le
crois c'est aussi ce qu'annonce le
président la république avec france 2030
oui après avoir dit pas ça dérisoire
aussi cogné avoir manié les 30 milliards
sur cinq ans sur différentes filières
moi je j'aime de moins en moins écoutés
jamais beaucoup aimé d'ailleurs écouter
emmanuel macron mais ce que j'aime
regarder ce qu'il fait il a commencé au
début de son quinquennat nous expliquer
qu'ils ne croyaient pas au nucléaire il
a dit des dizaines de fois dans les
mêmes mises en scène avec des grandes
tribunes des grands slogans etc il a
ensuite fermer fessenheim la centrale de
fessenheim ça c'est un acte c'est un
petit acte c'est un acte colossal
d'idées avec les écolos tonnes dit le
politique qui qui a été payé sur le dos
de fessenheim est aujourd'hui vient nous
dire qu'il croit au nucléaire quoi il a
changé d'avis pour vous parce qu'il voit
bien que l'état de l'opinion a changé
d'avis il voit bien qu'on ne peut pas
faire autrement que d'aller vers le
nucléaire et je veux le dire avec un
discours environnemental je suis très
préoccupé par la question
environnementale je pense que ma
génération c'est un sujet presque
instinctif mais l'urgence aujourd'hui
environnementale c'est l'urgence
climatique c'est la consommation de
l'émission de co2 c'est ça la véritable
urgence pour sauver la biodiversité
sauver les milieux naturels et la
meilleure manière de limiter notre rôle
notre
production de co2 pardon c'est de passer
par le nucléaire je pense que c'est une
énergie qui est aussi stratégique pour
notre industrie notre économie pour le
portefeuille des français que pour
l'environnement